Listen carefully to what Iván Espinosa de los Monteros de Vox
tells us but it is more important to be nice to everyone I
pay a lot of attention to the people I interact with every day,
people I work with or people I know lately.
How they treat others not how they treat me,
maybe I am now temporarily in a position where people want to show off.
There are also many people who want to dislike but that's not what I notice How
they treat the waiter how they treat the train conductor how they treat the
train conductor how they treat the cleaning lady when you are talking on a
table and someone a waiter puts you a glass of water It costs nothing to stop
and say thank you and continue with your conversation When you go to a place
where you have been well cared for it costs nothing
to look the cleaning lady in the eyes.
I don't know if you are going to leave him
or her with someone who is asking for money.
but there are times when I don't understand anything being nice
in Life is a decision that almost never almost never eh I
understand you And well what do you say What do you say to this Opinion.
Down here.